bonjour laurent jacobellis beaucoup nous
rejoindre merci à vous et et policiers
que ce matin vous être à porte parole de
marine le pen on est ensemble pendant 20
minutes pour une interview en
partenariat avec la presse quotidienne
régionale représenté par julien lécuyer
de la voix du nord aujourd'hui là un bon
jour yann bonjour monsieur le jeu qwiki
bonjour et on parle évidemment de cette
guerre en ukraine pour commencer et
laurent jacobellis nous ne sommes pas en
guerre avec la russie la russie l
agresseur est pas l'agressée est ce que
vous faites la même analyse qu emmanuel
macron hier soir oui bien sûr c'est une
évidence c'est la russie qui a agressé
l'ukraine et oui bien sûr il ya
aujourd'hui une guerre une crise de
tensions diplomatiques il faut régler
qu'il faut régler par le haut c'est à
dire par la diplomatie par les échanges
avec les deux parties prenantes
l'ukraine et la russie sans se placer
systématiquement dans un camp sans
devenir un belligérant et sans avoir de
déclarations trop forte comme
malheureusement ont pu la voir un
certain nombre de ministres et je crois
que dans ceux là le président de la
république hier a fait un constat assez
juste dans la première partie de son
interview de garder la voie diplomatique
ouverte et surtout celle ci est ce que
vous regrettez que la france par exemple
livre des armes à l'ukraine écoutez en
tout cas ça nous place effectivement
d'un certain côté je pense que plutôt
que de préparer la guerre il faut
préparer la paix c'est une évidence
c'est ce que demande marine le pen et
pour préparer la paix il faut parler
dialoguer et essayer de sortir par le
haut de la crise que nous traversons se
prépare
t il faut que le peuple ukrainien puisse
se défendre mais ce qui est inquiétant
ce qui est inquiétant dans cette affaire
c'est que les armes ont été commandés et
seront demain livré par l'union
européenne et la question se pose de
savoir quel mandat à l'union européenne
pour cela aucun statut ne lui défaire le
droit de commander des armes et de
participer à ce type de livraison dont
tout ça pose des questions nous en tant
que nation souveraine
je crois que le président de la
république le président de la république
emmanuel macron doigt par le dialogue
essayer de faire en sorte que cette
guerre comme il dit tout simplement une
question simple si marine le pen était
présidente en avril est-ce que vous
continueriez la livraison d'armes à
l'ukraine je ne peux pas répondre à sa
place ce que je sais c'est que
probablement les négociations auraient
commencé avant probablement nous aurions
eu une vision diplomatique et
géostratégiques plus indépendante d'une
france souveraine dans ses relations
d'une france qui ne soit pas forcément
comment dirais-je associé à un camp le
camp des américains le camp de l'union
européenne mais une france neutre qui
aurait dialoguer avec l'ukraine et avec
le président poutine pour tout faire
tout faire pour que jamais ce que nous
vivons aujourd'hui n'existe est ce que
est ce que pour vous le mot a été
prononcé par plusieurs candidats déjà
est-ce que poèmes pour vous l'admirent
poutine est un dictateur c'est un
pouvoir autoritaire clairement et c'est
aujourd'hui lui qui adresse l'ukraine je
crois que le constat que fait marine le
pen et que nous faisons tous crédit
foncier dans le vide à côté je suis pas
moi là pour définir les noms mais est ce
que vous croyez vraiment qu'il faut
aujourd'hui commencé à
donner des noms d'oiseaux à l'un et à
l'autre je pense que le constat il est
là c'est un régime autoritaire qui
effectivement je crois que l'invasion
l'agression de l'ukraine par le
président russe est hors du champ
démocratique
je crois que à partir du moment où ils
agressent un autre pays on assemble non
non puis ça qu'à partir du moment où il
y la grèce un autre pays c'était déjà le
cas en 2014 avec l'annexion de la de la
crimée et pourtant marine le pen dit le
président russe n'est plus tout à fait
le même qu'il ya cinq ans mais en fait
il ya cinq ans déjà
la demi-heure poutine faisait preuve
d'auto d'autoritarisme dans sa décision
de ses écrits mais j'entends votre
question mais vous savez marine le pen
elle a une vision des relations
internationales très pragmatique pour
toujours défendre l'intérêt est
évidemment supérieur de la paix dans le
monde et il a l'intérêt supérieur de la
nation française et pour ça les
interlocuteurs ils peuvent varier dans
le temps selon les lieux et selon les
conflits vladimir poutine vous savez
lorsqu'il a déclaré la chasse au
terrorisme islamiste était et devait
être un partenaire parce que nous avions
nous avons d'ailleurs en matière
d'islamisme toujours un ennemi commun
qui est venu sur notre sol tués des
françaises et des français et oui bien
sûr à ce moment là il faut dialoguer
avec vladimir poutine oui bien sûr à ce
moment là il faut rencontrer vladimir
poutine en revanche quand vladimir
poutine envahi et agressent l'ukraine là
évidemment la donne a changé mais c'est
pour ça que dans les relations
internationales marine le pen ne veut
pas être ficelé un camp ficelé à l'otan
ficelé aux américains ficelé à
l'allemagne ou à l'union européenne ou à
je ne sais qui il faut être pragmatique
dialoguer avec les interlocuteurs sur
vladimir poutine est ce que vous
regrettez ce que vous avez n'ai aucun
regret parce que au moment où il s'était
fait il y avait une raison de le faire
et c'était le bon interlocuteur marine
le pen aujourd'hui elle est candidate à
la présidence de la république française
et demain lorsqu elle accédera aux
affaires ce que je souhaite est que
beaucoup de français souhaite elle devra
avoir des relations avec l'ensemble des
dirigeants internationaux et pour ça il
faut commencer à les connaître le
travail l'a effectué d'avoir des
relations de dialoguer chantourner prix
de l'art et je me permets
je m'abonne forme de sous je me permets
termine en 2010 est elle cherchait un
peu son approbation je vais terminer ma
phrase et vous allez probablement mieux
comprendre si demain elle arrive aux
affaires elle connaîtra la quasi
totalité des dirigeants européens elle
connaîtra vladimir poutine ce sont des
gens avec qui le dialogue pourra
s'entamer du jour au lendemain il n'y
aura pas des mois de tâtonnements qui
seront perdre du temps notamment au
moment où on essaye de retrouver la paix
et je pense que faire ce procès
d'intention à marine le pen c'est
franchement de la mauvaise foi d'abord
parce que il faut le dire la quasi
totalité des dirigeants français ont
rencontré vladimir poutine et c'est
normal il est le président de la russie
jean
marie le pen rencontré marine le pen se
prépare à être présidente de la
république c'est probablement la
différence avec un certain nombre
d'autres candidats qui se permettent de
critiquer sans proposer je me permets
d'insister sur un point c'est que on a
entendu dire marie le pen qu'elle ne
croyait pas dans les sanctions
économiques et en même temps qu'ils ne
croyaient pas donc c'est vous le
rappeler dans l'envoi d'armement et
leurs dons que j'avais quand même vous
poser la question est ce qu'elle croit
en quoi il faut le lui demander
gentiment à vladimir poutine non il ya
la diplomatie la diplomatie ça passe
aussi par évidemment un certain nombre
de sanctions sur les os les oligarques
par exemple mais si demain la population
russe n'a plus de quoi manger et n'a
plus de quoi travailler est ce que vous
croyez vraiment que ce sera une solution
et fils et sanction vous savez quand
même que les premières victimes sont
souvent des entreprises françaises des
agriculteurs français on l'a vécu ces
dernières années
j'ai terminé c'est ce qu'on fait
excusez-moi sanctions économiques ou
passant le sens je vais terminer mon
propos parce que c'est vraiment un sujet
extrêmement important et on peut pas
répondre par oui pardon vous le vous
l'accordera prendre des sanctions faire
des embargos sur les échanges avec
l'union a vécu pendant avec la russie et
non pas l'union européenne avec la
russie c'est mettre nos agriculteurs par
exemple en difficulté qui ne pourront
plus exporter qui ne peuvent plus livrer
leurs biens alimentaires à la russie et
un certain nombre d'exploitations
agricoles françaises ont dû fermer est
ce que vous croyez c'est une solution
est-ce que ça a fait flancher une
seconde vladimir poutine est ce qu il a
changé de stratégie pas du tout donc
force est de constater que ce type de
sanction ne fonctionne pas long est ce
que vous croyez que c'est en interdisant
à un artiste russe de se produire à
paris qu' on va faire reculer vladimir
poutine il faut avoir une relation
diplomatique avec vladimir poutine
marine le pen n'a pas dit non à
certaines sanctions mais des sanctions
qui visent le pouvoir russe mais qui ne
visent pas la population et qui ne vise
pas les entreprises françaises nous on
ne touche qu aux oligarques c'est sony
par exemple
le fait que des flux financiers toujours
plus aux oligarques vous touchez à la
population derrière attendez vous
toucher d'abord au premier cercle de la
lumière poutine et donc vous avez là une
possibilité d'action moi ce que je
regrette c'est ce que reconnaît qu'une
regrettons tous c'est que
la voie diplomatique
honnêtement n'a pas été exploité
explorer à 100% il y a toujours eu il y
a toujours eu une vision bloc contre
bloc est malheureuse et malheureusement
aujourd'hui nous sommes dans cette
situation de qu'il faut reprendre la
diplomatie jusqu'au maximum
il a passé des
est-ce que tu aimes c'est compliqué vu
l'appel de la can vous souvenez des
images avec huit morts emmanuel macron
honnêtement fait joue son rôle de
président de la république il n'est pas
question ici
voilà deux d'utiliser la campagne
électorale pour essayer de le
discréditer dans sa démarche il a au
moins le courage de prendre son
téléphone d'aller voir vladimir poutine
est d'essayer des choses force est de
constater cependant qu'il n'ya pas il
n'y est pas arrivé pourquoi parce qu'ils
les pieds et mains liés avec le
commandement stratégique de l'otan avec
un certain nombre d'accords
internationaux qui fait que quand il va
voir vladimir poutine il est vu comme un
émissaire du camp adverse et non pas
comme un interlocuteur neutre marine le
pen
elle a une référence j'allais dire en
matière de politique internationale et
de stratégie géopolitique c'est le
général de gaulle qui avait placé la
france dans une situation de non alignés
de fait est qu'ils pouvaient diallo et
avec tout le monde fallait le faire est
ce qu'on peut vraiment comparer la
situation de la france dans les années
60 à la france des années 2020 et est ce
que vous pensez sérieusement que la
france aurait une voix qui porte plus en
dehors de l'otan qu'à l'intérieur moi je
crois que oui je pense que d'abord on ne
veut pas être en dehors de l'otan et en
dehors du commandement intégré de l'otan
mais je pense que oui il y avait besoin
d'une grande nation indépendante qui
dialoguent avec tout le monde qui lorsqu
il y à des tensions internationales
mettent en lien les uns avec les autres
mais pour ça ça veut dire que il faut
dialoguer en multilatérale ou bilatérale
en fonction des crises en fonction des
interlocuteurs
mais penser qu'on va vivre sans jamais
travaillé ou dialoguer avec la chine
sans jamais travaillé ou dialoguer avec
la russie c'est une vision un peu naïve
du monde voilà il faut être vu la
personne évidemment qu'il faut et
d'ailleurs le canada mais qui ont pu
avec le talent alors mettons le en
pratique le demeurer l'inscrit demandent
l'entrée de son pays de l'ukraine dans
l'union européenne est ce que si marine
le pen est présidente elle dira oui
non non pour deux raisons d'abord
excusez moi mais là on est un peu dans
la communication c'est à dire qu'on sait
très bien que le processus d'adhésion ne
prend pas une semaine l'entamé ça ça
prend des années ça prend des années on
faut l'entamer où il faut leur dire non
il peut y avoir une volonté marquée du
parc des moulins est d'abord si un jour
l'ukraine de rentrée de l'union
européenne j'espère que le conflit sera
fini c'est axa prend tellement de temps
que nous on peut espérer que dans trois
quatre cinq ans ce conflit sera terminé
et même bien avant
deuxièmement marine le pen a été très
clair nous sommes contre toute nouvelle
adhésion à l'union européenne je pense
que la réponse est limpide
oui il ya quelques mois encore lors de
la chute de kaboul le rassemblement
national avait lancé une pétition pour
s'opposer à l'accueil des réfugiés
afghans en france aujourd'hui vous
soutenez l'accueil des réfugiés
ukrainien pourquoi une telle différence
de traitement c'est très simple d'abord
aujourd'hui les réfugiés ukrainien qui
veulent quitter leur pays et être
accueillis dans d'autres pays de
l'europe sont des femmes et des enfants
qui fuient la guerre les hommes restent
sur place et combattre la différence
c'est qu'un pays a été agressé et nous
l'avons dit en début d'entretien kabous
et el hadi fait la différence c'est
autre chose c'est que c'est un pays qui
avait changé pouvoir deuxièmement ce qui
vous avez vu les images - la difficulté
bien sûr vous avez vu les images de ceux
qui fuyaient kaboul une très large
majorité c'étaient des hommes des hommes
qui auraient pu rester sur place et
combattre pour leurs idées or la france
elle a effectivement dans sa tradition
le devoir d'accueillir des réfugiés qui
fuient la guerre mais qui fuit
réellement la guerre et je pense que les
deux cas ne sont pas comparables et puis
soyons honnête aussi l'ukraine est un
pays de l'europe pas au sens union
européenne mais au sens géographique et
que donc nous sommes un pays proche
physiquement de l'ukraine et qu'il est
naturel que nous accueillons des gens
qui fuient la guerre si demain il y à
une guerre dans un pays d'amérique du
sud ou d'afrique clairement les réfugiés
trouveront accueil dans les pays voisins
c'est un peu caricatural mais c'est
quand même ça y ressemble mais on a
l'impression quand même que vous portez
vos travers de ceux de cette
argumentation l'idée qu' il ya des bons
et des mauvais réfugiés non être des
réfugiés s'étaient battus alors et j'ai
bien compris c'est jamais sait jamais
une situation simple en revanche il ya
des réfugiés qui effectivement fui la
guerre et cela on doit les accueillir
comme c'est le cas de l'ukraine parce
que ce sont des femmes et des enfants
qui une fois encore ne vont pas au
combat mais fui les combats et puis il y
à des réfugiés qui eux viennent de pays
qui sont d'ailleurs dans le statut de
réfugié un peu qu'ils ne sont pas dans
ce statut de réfugié puisque ils fuient
leur gouvernement qui n'était pas
occulter ces deux communautés qui
utilisent voies migratoires et qui dans
ces flux migratoires cash il faut le
dire un certain nombre de terroristes
qui veulent attaquer la france ça a été
le cas depuis la syrie ça a été le cas
depuis l'irak ça a était potentiellement
le cas depuis l'afghanistan où des
djihadistes un filtrer les flux
migratoires le rôle d'un président de la
république et ce sera la vie marine le
pen c'est de protéger d'abord et avant
tout les français donc juste quand il
exhume on dit que ces réfugiés dollar
reste en pologne pour vous il se trompe
oui
très bien est ce que vous êtes convaincu
par le projet d'élaborer un plan de
résilience économique et social et
concrètement derrière cette question il
ya l'idée de savoir si on doit accepter
le prix de la paix de la liberté de la
démocratie je cite le président de la
république moi je suis heureux que le
président de la république à la fin de
son mandat entrevoit la lumière vous
savez ça veut dire qu'il n'est jamais
trop tard pour bien faire il se rend
compte qu'il est nécessaire d'avoir une
souveraineté alimentaire une
souveraineté économique une souveraineté
en termes de matières premières
notamment énergétiques
parce que si on livre le sort de la
france à des pays étrangers et bien ça
veut dire qu'on expose notre population
à tous les dangers tous les risques mais
que fait-il pour sa qu'at-il fait
malheureusement rien il a signé et
participer à tous les traités libre
échange qui font que notre agriculture
aujourd'hui est en proie à une
concurrence déloyale et que nous ne
sommes plus malheureusement indépendant
en termes de d'alimentation et
d'agriculture que nous dépendons des
pays étrangers il faut aider à la fois
notre agriculture et retrouver la
souveraineté alimentaire le président de
la république parle aussi de
souveraineté européenne mais c'est un
non sens ça veut dire la dissolution de
la souveraineté de la france dans un
espace plus grand ça veut dire que
lui-même
prononce le mot souveraineté il dissout
l'idée de souveraineté c'est quand même
un paradoxe à paradoxe tout mac rognan
il est englué dans ses contradictions on
c'est à dire que les événements nous
donnent raison
la crise sanitaire a montré qu'il
fallait être indépendant en matière
sanitaire en matière alimentaire en
matière énergétique
les terribles affrontements que l'on
connaît aujourd'hui en ukraine montre
bien qu'on ne peut pas dépendre
notamment énergétiquement d'autres pays
comme de la russie pour le gaz ce qui
n'est d'ailleurs pas complètement le cas
de la france ça veut dire que sa
politique par exemple énergétique
des éoliennes etc qui font que on a
besoin au final 2 2 de pétrole et de gaz
pour faire fonctionner l'énergie en
france l'abandon
la france
pour le moins audacieuse russe en est on
est bien d'accord la différence de
l'allemagne ou de l'italie bien sûr mais
en terme de pétrole vous reconnaîtrez
avec moi qu'on sent produisons peu et
que nous dépendons de puissances
étrangères
il fallait mettre l'accent d'un côté sur
notre agriculture et des non
agriculteurs et non pas le livrer à la
concurrence mondiale pour l'indépendance
alimentaire et développer le nucléaire
plutôt que de le détruire comme il l'a
fait là aussi à ces dernières semaines
pour assurer l'indépendance énergétique
de la france alors je pense que porte
marine le pen depuis des années et
malheureusement ce que les terribles
faits que nous traversons aujourd'hui la
terrible crise que nous traversons
aujourd'hui valide mais dont elle
semblait dans le remix de la crise et
ukrainienne est ce que vous ne pensez
pas nécessaire de soutenir le projet de
renforcer la souveraineté indépendante
la souveraineté énergétique européenne
ainsi que le projet de défense
européenne ça ne veut rien dire la
souveraineté énergétique leur peine
excusez moi et avec une souveraineté
c'est celle d'une nation et à qu'une
nation c'est la france pour nous donc
oui la souveraineté française mais
surtout protégeons les français parce
que on a le prix je termine là dessus
c'est très important le prix du litre à
2 euros la multiplication par quatre du
prix du gaz va pousser des familles
françaises dans la misère il faut
d'urgence faire et appliquer ce que
demande marine le pen baisser la tva sur
les biens énergétiques de 20 pour la
communauté de la même question de survie
pour beaucoup de français emmanuel
macron n'a toujours pas déclaré sa
candidature il a raison vu le contexte
on peut comprendre aujourd'hui que je le
contexte il ils attendent mais vous
savez ce sera fait demain puisque le
dépôt des candidatures aura lieu demain
en revanche il a quand même tarder même
avant la crise ukrainienne on a bien
compris qu'il jouait de son statut de
président de la république pour sortir
le chéquier d'un côté pour utiliser les
médias de l'autre sans participer aux
mêmes règles que les autres candidats
normalement demain tous à apprendre afin
emmanuel macron ce n'est pas une
surprise sera candidat de la république
et ceux qui ont regardé son intervention
hier l'ont compris puisqu'il a commencé
l'intervention en tant que président de
la république pendant les 2/3 de
l'interview l'interview et qu'il a finie
quand même comme dida en se plaçant sur
l'avenir en proposant un certain nombre
de mesures donc tout ça c'est un jeu de
dupes qui se terminera demain et tant
mieux parce qu'il a un bilan et face à
ce bilan marine le pen a un projet il va
falloir comment parle de ce milan sur
l'immigration qui a explosé sur la
sécurité qui a explosé d'autant que
sacha qui a tout ça ne va pas être fait
par là par la crise et craignait une
vraie difficulté autour de autour de
cette crise et quelles on a là on a on
croit qu on a bien la crainte ce que les
électeurs n'en tourne pas du tout les
autres sujets portant le président de
mâcon hier a promis un débat
démocratique
alors en même temps il veut pas
participer je crois aux débats du
premier tour ce qui est très surprenant
pour
évidemment à partir du moment où il est
candidat il doit débattre en tant que
candidat il doit défendre son bilan ce
bilan que nous allons attaquer contre
lequel nous allons faire des
propositions parce que ce café macron
objectivement a détruit un certain
nombre
d'industries a
rendu les flux migratoires beaucoup plus
facile et donc a mis en danger un
certain nombre de valeurs qui sont les
nôtres et notre sécurité tout ça il va
falloir en parler tout ça il va falloir
faire bilan contre mesures et il est
temps de le faire il nous reste quelques
semaines en revanche est un débat qui
est prévu entre valérie pécresse et eric
zemmour ce sera la semaine prochaine est
ce que marine le pen a prévu de débattre
avec les données de marine le pen avait
proposé un débat valérie pécresse
valérie pécresse je crois l'avait
refusée mais il y aura des débats il y
aura des débats avec toi
j'ai écouté je crois que pour l'instant
celui qu'elle avait proposé à valérie
pécresse avait été refusée mais
peut-être que ça a changé peut-être que
vous avez des informations bon alors
vous êtes passés là tout juste depuis
mardi à 503 parrainage
que vous même vous étiez en
responsabilité et autant de 7 millions
dû suer des grosses gouttes pendant
quelques temps je l'imaginais ce qu on
dit merci françois bayrou alors
honnêtement assez 503 parrainage que
nous avons obtenus c'est le fruit du
travail de nos élus de nos militants sur
le terrain signature du de la banque des
parrainages portée par françois bayrou
pas que je sache mais vous savez c'est
pas marqué sur les
i la quasi-totalité des parrainages que
nous avons obtenus ne sont pas une
surprise puisqu'une ont été acquis par
nos équipes il n'y a pas encore le
parrainage de françois bayrou mais je
veux pas minimiser pour être très
honnête au rôle de françois bayrou dans
cette affaire d'abord on peut l'accuser
d'être proche de nos de nos idées et
pourtant il a sonné le signal d'alarmé
ce qui veut dire qu'il y avait un vrai
danger démocratique avec ce système
obsolète des parrainages rendu public
comme ils sont aujourd'hui en ouvrant la
banque des parrainages il a montré qu'un
certain nombre de maires étaient prêts à
parrainer contrairement à ce qu'on
disait mais sous une forme d'anonymat
parce que cette banque cette bourse des
parrainages une forme d'anonymat assuré
aux élus qui parraine ce qui veut bien
dire que il faut demain rétablir
l'anonymat des parrainages pour que les
mères se sentent pas de parrainage
citoyen selon vous mais plutôt le retour
à l'anonymat qu'il fallait avoir une
profondeur le système
simplement levé la publicité des noms
les élus devrait déjà nous permettre d'y
voir beaucoup plus clair questions sur
marion maréchal lui parce qu'après
nicolas bay gilbert collard je vais pas
tous les tous les sites évidemment
courrier ça vous prend d'aller prendre
second dix ans ils sont huit oui mais
bon ce serait l'effet d'accumulation
serait peut-être beaucoup plus de temps
de citer tous les élus qui sont restés
fidèles à marine le pen c'est à 90 62
élus là il faudrait ouvrir l'antenne
pendant trois jours alors donc cela dit
on parlait du ralliement de marion
maréchal-le pen à partir de dimanche
lors du prochain meeting de d'eric
zemmour est ce que c'est un nouveau coup
dur pour marine le pen marion
maréchal-le pen n'est plus adhérente du
rassemblement national depuis quelques
années elle a pris son indépendance pour
son école elle c'est un secret de
polichinelle
en politique elle sait pas elle va
rejoindre eric zemmour c'est quelque
chose qui est orchestrée préparer
notamment avec la presse depuis quelques
temps c'est son choix
c'est un mauvais paix c'est un mauvais
choix qu'elle devra assumer parce que
soit elle veut qu'on remplace emmanuel
macron et qu'on mette enfin une
politique d'une france souveraine forte
fier qui défendent les français est la
seule alternative possible c'est marine
le pen les sondages le montrent soit
elle soutint un candidat de témoignage
qui n'a aucune chance d'être au second
tour et même s'il est au second tour qui
n'aurait aucune chance de battre
emmanuel macron et dans ce cas là c'est
que c'est pas l'intérêt de la france qui
prime ce sont des intérêts particuliers
des intérêts politiciens une stratégie
de billard à trois bandes pour 2000
combien en 2030 et quelques voilà
simplement nationale en partie du passé
le fait que marion maréchal-le pen
reviennent en politique et qu'elle
choisisse reconquête au moment où les
français sont d'accord avec l'ensemble
de nos idées au moment où les français
disent que marine le pen a la stature
d'une femme d'état qu'ils peuvent lui
faire confiance
non au contraire nous sommes
terriblement moderne terriblement
moderne de nos idées les crises que nous
venons traversée montre que la
souveraineté est une idée moderne est
essentielle je crois que les français
partagent nos constats sur l'immigration
sur la sécurité l'ensemble des
propositions faites par marine le pen
sont des propositions de bon sens qui si
elle avait été appliquée depuis cinq ans
il n'aurait pas amener notre pays dans
la situation où il est vous savez je
suis toujours très dubitatif sur les
sondages mais au bout d'un moment quand
ils disent tous la même chose qu'eux au
second tour à la seule capable d'arriver
c'est marine le pen et que la seule
capable
non c'est vrai mais aujourd'hui elle est
donnée dans certains sondages à 47%
c'est donc la principale opposante et la
plus haute dans les sondages face à
emmanuel macron donc la seule qui soit
dans ce qu'on appelle dans les sondages
la marge d'erreur et qui avec une
dynamique parce qu'il est une dynamique
en politique peut demain battre emmanuel
macron le choix quand les français
aujourd'hui c'est est ce qu'on continue
50 plus avec emmanuel macron stop ou
encore si c'est stop à mâcon ça veut
dire votez marine le pen et surtout
aller voter parce que l'abstention c'est
faire le jeu de mah contre dana
questions sur une actualité d'hier c'est
yvan colonna condamné pour l'assassinât
du préfet erignac qui est entre la vie
et la mort après avoir été étranglée par
un co détenu dans la prison d'al co
détenu condamné lui pour association de
malfaiteurs en vue de la préparation
d'un acte terroriste c'était un ancien
jihadiste en afghanistan gilles simeoni
le président du conseil exécutif de
corse dit que l'état porte une
responsabilité accablante ce sont ces
mots vous êtes d'accord bien sûr en
dehors de ce que défendent les uns et
les autres il n'a pas été condamnés à
mort dont il n'a pas à être tué en
prison notamment par un apprentis
djihadistes et ça pose de vraies
questions ça pose de vraies questions et
si monsieur dupont moretti qui devrait
vous répondre pourquoi est ce qui se
passe ce genre d'action de nos prisons
pourquoi est ce que la sécurité des
prisonniers n'est pas garanti pourquoi
est ce qu'on ne sait pas plus de places
de prison pourquoi est ce que les
djihadistes ne sont pas mis à l'
isolement dans des prisons spécifique
parce que ce sont des individus
dangereux qui veulent tuer pour leur
idéologie tout ça montre bien la
faiblesse aujourd'hui de notre justice
en france et je crois que c'est une
leçon que devrait prendre le
gouvernement met enfin pour les quelques
semaines qui lui reste nous nous
impliquerons une autre polly et ancien
responsabilité de l'état dans sa tête et
oui forcément parce qu'il ya eu un
moment un manque de vigilance est donc
oui l'état est responsable aujourd'hui
du système carcéral merci laurent jats
comédien
[Musique]